hey uh it's Addison ray and today I'm
gonna be binging BuzzFeed quizzes
alright let's get started the first quiz
I'm gonna take is how much tik-tok slang
do you know I feel pretty confident in
my tick-tock slang but I'm not a hundred
percent sure because I don't know if I
ever put true names to like motions the
first question is what is this call it's
like a split screen of two people and
they're like doing the same motion the
first option is a combo the second is a
duet the third is a challenge and the
fourth is a copycat out of my knowledge
of tech chalk I'm gonna go ahead and say
this is a duet because it's like a split
screen and usually that's what it looks
like when we do it and I was right it
was it do it what's it called when
someone is the best at doing something
we'll use twerking as an example CEO of
twerking twerk master king of twerking
and the fourth one is supreme ruler of
torquing so I'm gonna go ahead and go
with my first instinct which is CEO
because that was a huge trend for a
while people to be a CEO of things and I
was right so my tick-tock sling is
looking pretty nice so far the third
question is what's this dance move
called it's like a screenshot from a
video that James and I did our butts are
out so the first option is body roll
second option is hitting the low third
option is the clown and fourth option is
throwing it back with our angles of our
bodies I'm gonna have to go with
throwing it back and it was right yeah
shut up James for throwing it back with
me in that video what's the name of the
main feed where you scroll through
popular videos the talk feed the
tick-tock sphere which is really cool
actually
the for you page and the fourth is the
zone so as much as I want to say the
tick-tock sphere because that sounds
really cool
it's definitely the for youth page so
yep it's the for you page
what does someone on the app possess
when everyone thinks they're great the
cheer the stand the mob or the height so
this is the
yep all right what does it mean if
someone comments this emoji on a
tick-tock a fishing line with a hook and
a 15 ohm hook
they think the posts the poster is
fishing for compliments they think the
poster is a catfish they've caught the
poster doing something bad they think
the poster looks like a fish I am going
to go ahead and say that it is they
think the poster is fishing for
compliments and it was right I think
it's fair to say bye now Mike we know
Mighty Ducks slang is pretty up to par
which to the following is not a check
trend on tick tock so like there's this
trend on tick tock words like blah blah
blah
check having a boyfriend that's ten
times hotter than you check second is my
dad is an astronaut check the third is
rich kid check and the fourth is
something traumatic happened that
changed my life too so as you can tell I
for sure know the last one is one this
one is honestly probably gonna be one
that I might get wrong because now that
I'm thinking about it I don't know rich
kid check I'm pretty sure that's one I'm
gonna have to go with my dad as an
astronaut try cuz I don't think I've
heard that one but I feel like that's
totally something that would be on tick
tock and be normal okay I was right so
there's not in my dad as an astronaut
check but I'm sure someone will come up
with that and I'm if they haven't
already
what does it mean if someone comments
this emoji on a tick tock and the emoji
is an hourglass they think the video was
too long they thought the video was
boring they think the poster has an
hourglass figure they think the poster
is out of good ideas I'm gonna go as
they think the poster has an hourglass
figure
yeah that's what it was what is a simp
the options are a guy who sucks up to a
girl someone who is dumb a person who is
really sympathetic or a girl who is
really cute and shy I'm gonna go with a
guy who sucks up to ago and I was right
people sometimes overuse the word sit
and I think it's just sometimes people
be next what's it called when someone
makes a video explaining what happened
to them and another one of their videos
number one the explainer number two
about me number three vibe tech number
four story time I'm gonna go with
stories time because it's pretty much a
story about what happened
so I got a 10 out of 10 you live and
breathe tic TOCs so it makes sense that
you're totally fluent in tic TOCs like
when you're not making videos you're
scrolling through before you page and
laughing your butt off I have to agree
I love Tech Talk and I'm obviously on it
a lot because I know all of these pretty
quickly so I guess I'm a ginger all
right so the next quiz I'm gonna take is
this aesthetics quiz will reveal your
age with 99% accuracy this is a bold
statement all right so the first
question is which photo makes you feel
happy
so the first photo I see is like a
colorful explosion the second photo is
like it looks like almost granite but it
looks like it's water with like dye in
it the third one is like a cloud the
fourth one is a statue with goggles on
on a pastel pink wall the fifth one I
think it looks like a dragon fruit
exploded the last photo is a photo of a
woman and she has like it looks like
like goggles but like I'm made of
flowers I'm gonna go with the dragon for
exploding and I I don't know actually
that's for sure of driving through but
it looks like one which photo makes you
feel uneasy a like bunch of bananas with
like a glitch scream then there's a
photo of a girl it's almost a glitch as
well and then the third photo is like
frosty looking next one is like a bell
pepper a pink bell pepper with paint
dripping on it the next one is two
people sitting on a couch and like the
middle of the woods and then the last
one is a mouth like this with flowers
blooming from the top I'm gonna say the
people that was like frozen that makes
me feel uneasy which photo makes you
feel confused the first one it's like it
looks like an island and then like you
see like a barrier and then like on the
other side looks like an ocean the next
one is a girl with like tie-dye covering
her face kind of and then there's one of
two people walking and holding hands
with animal masks on the next one is a
girl
it looks like it's someone that's it
with their legs like criss cross the
next one is in Alien holding balloons
and the last one - penguins sitting on a
chair so I'm gonna go with the first one
the barrier and the islands I feel like
it's kind of confusing because I don't
know what the barrier is actually I
changed my mind I'm gonna go with the
Penguins on the chair because I'm
wondering what they're doing there and
what they're watching
which photo makes you feel nostalgic
first one is a girl and she's like
holding her arms out and there's like it
almost looks like smoke but in the smoke
is like flowers a monkey on a couch
old-school telephone but it's a pink
so everything's Pinker on it the next
one is like a dining room very full of
patterns the next one is a girl and she
has like a pink paint swipe across her
eyes the last one is a room and it's
like a bunch of stuff but there's a
Dalmatian sitting on the middle table
this is hard
probably the Dalmatian one I like it I
like dog which photo it makes you feel
energized the first photo is people like
laying over overlapping on each other
and the next one is a pink and orange
tunnel type thing the next one is
somebody with their arms up the next one
is it's like a person floating in the
sky the fifth one is a square with like
a burst of like smoke on one side of it
and then the last one is like a party
scene my first instinct is to go with
the orange and pink rocks but I'm
looking at like the party scene it's
kind of energizing me in a way I'm just
gonna have to go with my first instinct
so I'm gonna go with the pink in the
orange next up is which photo it makes
you feel nervous the first photo is like
an ocean with like a storm over it the
second photo is a like crowds of people
at the beach the third photo is glitched
out and the next one is a house on top
of a rock the fifth one is somebody with
lights it's like hanging in their mouth
and then the sixth one is like desert
view with like a sunset probably the
storm I get like really scared when
there's a storm and
only there's not very many storms in
California but when I'm from in
Louisiana there there's always like
storms and when they do have them they
like really bad finally which photo
makes you feel optimistic first photo is
a pond with like flowers in it then
there's a photo of a guy and there's
like flowers and the protection of his
glasses and then the next one is lights
so a blue purple white lights in the
room and then there's a giraffe with his
head in the clouds and then there's a
hand like holding out like twinkles
and then a person with the flower over
their face so I'm gonna go with the
giraffe with his head in the clouds so I
am 26 years old I am young free and
living the best years of my life I've
already experienced so many fun things
but I have so much more waiting it's
about six and a half years off but I'd
say that's pretty close I guess maybe I
just smashed Thank You papa older age
alright so the next quiz I'm gonna take
is what's the color palette of your
personality first off how do you think
others perceive you when they first meet
you the first option is soft-spoken the
second is life of the party the third is
thoughtful the fourth is friendly the
fifth is energetic and the sixth is kind
of rude tbh I think people would say I'm
energetic for sure
the next question is how would the
people who know you well describe you
loyal sensitive passionate forgiving
supportive or caring I would say my
friends are people that know me well
would describe me as supportive which
three words would you use to describe
yourself the first option is extroverted
loyal and creative the second is
introverted intuitive and helpful
introverted determine artistic
extroverted athletic kind hard-working
extroverted talented introverted funny
and sarcastic I probably say extroverted
hardworking and talented that kind of
feels weird saying yeah I think I'm
pretty hard working in I'm definitely
extroverted when do you most feel truly
about yourself when I'm with my family
when I was
friends when I'm by myself when I'm in
front of an audience when I'm being
active or when I'm at work / school when
I feel most truly myself I feel like
when I'm with my friends and lastly what
color do you most identify with
so there's red yellow blue green purple
and pink and I'm going to say I'm most
identify with yellow alright my color
palette of my personality is the soft
morning palette you're caring sweet and
always there for the ones you love you
ultimately love nights in with the best
friends which is so true it's pretty
accurate pretty much to tea I love
nights with my best friends so thank you
so much BuzzFeed for all the quizzes
apparently I'm a 26-year old tic-tock
pro who has a soft morning color palette
as a personality um don't forget to
follow me on tic toc at addison r.e.m on
instagram addison ray TUI's at the end
and eyes have an amazing day thank you
so much BuzzFeed
[Music]